il ya des coups de coeur et les coups de
gueule ses secrets mais démission dans
laquelle on va parler télévision à
laquelle on va parler du programme a
bien sûr que les programmes sont la
teinte c'est partir culture voilà à
l'essai ça fait partie de l'anniversaire
sais pas où vous avez alors la régie son
anniversaire aussi ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qu'il a qu'est ce que ça
marche pas le happening mais qui me
parle là qui me parle il est sûr qu'à
taux de 2,8 ya la foule ce gars il est
venu pour mon anniversaire dieu arrêts
et a retiré la trouvez comment
l'anniversaire et alla tout le monde
tout ça il est venu qu avant
l'anniversaire dieu est dur il est où là
on peut le voir
non non non tu ne peux pas le voir
baba
et ça les a pas si vous en avez pensé
c'était fort déjà ça la ligue
attention là les gars on n'est pas à
civile de mémoire de téléspectateurs
dieu on l'a jamais entendu nulle part
ouais on entendu si mes vues n'ont donc
bon je peux dire que peut mettre
n'importe qui ça peut être n'importe qui
et je connais sa voix là c'est pas dieu
mais c'est vers notre gars qui se fait
passer pour lui et sur le trou ça va
chier pour sa gueule à les coups de
coeur coups de gueule alors c'est donc
vous qui avez vous avez un coup de coeur
gilles verdez devrait d'ailleurs vous
êtes là oui il est troublé merci d'être
là oui pour destin brisé
ouais nouvelle émission hier soir sur
tmc à 20h50 avec sandrine corman ça
raconte le parcours de gens qui nous ont
bouleversés
il y avait de l'émotion de la passion
moi j'en frissonne encore si vous voulez
on peut regarder un extrait alors on va
pas regarder un extrait on va regarder
surtout le côté anxiogène de l'émission
d'hier ce soir dans tous vos postes
on va se marrer on a rigolé on sait pas
du tout ce qui va mal à chaque fois que
l'on sait un truc ce n'est pas ce qui va
se passer mais hier c'est viril pour ces
cas une chose c'était nous angoisser ça
veut dire les pauvres ceux qui se sont
couchés après avoir vu cette émission
sur la tête d'un chat et se sont
réveillés ce matin c'était à base de
chaux au bout du rouleau je veux pas
ligne par le valais nous par regarde
regarde aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en mer dit que tu commencé à s'énerver
la mission
[Applaudissements]
alors l'ex c'est ça la surprise c'est
mon ex en régie les gars à quoi bon
travailler mais c'est ça c'est marrant
ça et les gages courant de rien dans
cette émission ça donne c'est toi c'est
quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dieu du ciel au dessus du pain tout le
dieu de coire de l'humour
non mais c'est pas votre adversaire
c'est votre fête en fait il faut plus
parler le gars mairie en tout cas il est
très sympa merci c'est très très réussit
puisque ya un mec qui me saoule la mdi
sourit un peu le dieu du paf la sega
jega si je vous jure si elle est ce que
voulait quitter par corriger rochelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que
avais tu parles dans la région et c'est
parce qu'il veut c'est quoi ça il
revient si tu as des couilles et on me
dit viens viens si t'es un homme
enfin il m'a même dit au pire que ça je
vous le dis on va voir qui c'est parce
que je commence à en avoir assez
c'est qui ça c'est qui c'est qui c'est
qui est leur problème technique est avec
toi
et en fait c'est pas moi la surprise
jean surprise pour toi retour sur scène
il ya une énorme star cas où les trois
dramas visite non mais moi je suis juste
l'assistante cette personne il faut que
tu viennes avec moi non tu connais
l'endroit où tu as des gens dedans
cacher vraiment ça s'appelle déjà
les gens ils en cash et ussel à la boîte
et a toujours une star faut deviner qui
est de la capitale neuf et bien dans la
cabine have love tu vas devoir
ouais deviner enfin tu va voir qui est
dedans je pense à te faire plaisir à
tous et doit pas s quatrième
anniversaire on avait fait un gros dos
attend il ya un énorme de sa non non bon
succès comme plus tard
même une surprise anglaise ivan pesic
dit tu m'as l'inca lui raconter attaque
est passé ça je vais bientôt tout
d'accord j'attends beaucoup fait la
surprise après du broker
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
t'es pas venu tout seul
voilà
[Rires]
les gars ça parce qu elle soit raboté
les gaffes à raboter non moi même si un
truc à mai mois quelque chose d'indécent
et vous êtes déchets nous assurait les
gars on voit alors on voit pas c'est
beau c'est la nouvelle la bleue écoute
je sais pas moi je viens d'arriver
on va dire toi et tu le prends tu
l'amène dans la cabine d'un bluff c'est
tous les chats alors je crois qu'elle
quelqu'un donc là qu'est ce que je dois
faire
donc là c'est bon là la surprise est
arrivée ou pas dans la kapisa ben là
c'est génial hein c'est à oui c'est
suffisament cocon qui pend comment du
cadeau roger t'aimais je t'aime époque
marges et les façons région je vous
explique
c'est mon anniversaire aujourd'hui et
donc je ne sais pas du tout ce qui se
passe dans cette émission les
chroniqueurs non plus hein et voilà si
on est en direct donc est-ce que je peux
regarder ce qu'il ya dans la cabine les
chéris ça fait lourd car il n'avait pas
vu c'est tout ce que je peux te dire oui
c'est ce qui vient de me dire merci
c'est une vraie surprise je mette la
tête 0-2 la tête sic mais je dois dire
ce que c'est où
[Applaudissements]
jean le semblant sa part du lion